alexis poulain journaliste co fondateur
du site le monde moderne
alexis pour la merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors pour
commencer une réaction sur le dernier
bilan pour la quatrième journée
consécutive le nombre de personnes
hospitalisées en réanimation en france a
baissé
est ce qu'on peut parler d'une stratégie
payante finalement pour l'exécutif
oui finalement l'agitation des derniers
jours fait que au moins pour ce qui est
des urgences le choix de tgv sanitaire
d'avion sanitaires d'avoir essayé de
multiplier et les places d'accueil en
réanimation à payer maintenant il faut
voir qu'on est on parle plus de piques
qui est devant nous et d'un plateau
épidémique donc finalement d'une crise
qui est là pour durer pour s'installer
donc il va falloir continuer de gérer la
ou peut-être des régions qui ne sont pas
touchés aujourd'hui vont petit à petit
avoir le même problème de gestion de des
malades qui vont être signés nation donc
ça reste à voir mais évidemment on ne
peut que se réjouir de ces chiffres où
on voit le nombre de gens qui sortent de
réanimation et ça c'est quand même
quelque chose ou on doit dire merci à
nos soignants qui font un travail
exceptionnel
alors on vient de l'évoquer 1 c'est la
perte de confiance des français envers
le gouvernement elle s'accentue ces
derniers jours dans la gestion de la
crise du coronavirus elle vient d'où
selon vous cette défiance très
simplement je pense qu'il est trop de
mensonges
d'une part on a entendu les déclarations
de mise de l'intérieur christophe
castaner qui avouait devant les
sénateurs que non les masses que n'avait
pas été réquisitionnée pour les régions
et puis qui deux jours après 10 a en
fait si les mensonges de la porte en lui
gouvernement qui disait n'importe quoi
sur les masques avant finalement qu'on
se rend compte que les masques elles
vont être utile donc il va falloir
changer totalement la stratégie de
communication une communication que les
gens ont du mal à comprendre c'est à
dire que les amendes c'est un jour si on
doit porter le masque obligatoire et
puis non et puis on ne sait pas trop on
a beaucoup de remontées de français qui
sont qui pense bien faire remplir la
fiche pour pouvoir sortir de chez eux et
qu'ils se font verbaliser qui ne
comprennent pas pourquoi qui vont bien
sûr demander à des comptes savoir
pourquoi j'ai été verbalisé
alors que je faisais rien de mal et que
j'avais rempli ma fiche
donc il ya une vraie communication qui
est beaucoup trop brouillonne pour que
les gens aient confiance et je pense que
c'est le mensonge d'abord qui fait que
les gens ont perdu la confiance est
beaucoup trop de communication et pas
assez d'action est aujourd'hui qu'est ce
qui manque c'est des masques cd tester
tout ça qu'on n'a pas de réponse dans
les grands discours
on attend on est dans la tente dans
l'expectative alors pas de réponse dans
les grands discours justement on en
attend un ce sera demain soir emmanuel
macron à qui s'exprime pour la quatrième
fois depuis le début de la crise
concrètement qu'est ce que vous en
attendez vous de cette prise de parole
et on attend de savoir la durée de
confinement à savoir est-ce qu'on va
aller au delà de ce qui ce qui est
attendu le 15 avril me semble bien
bientôt compte tenu du plateau
épidémique devant nous on attend bien
sûr des réponses sur les masques y
aura-t-il une distribution des masques à
la population sur les tests sur un petit
des tests massif sur ses réponses la
concrète avec des chiffres sur aussi les
aides que vont pouvoir avoir les
entreprises parce que plus on confine
plus les entreprises auront du mal
finalement à à ne pas déposer le bilan à
pouvoir sauver cette année qui va être
catastrophique pour beaucoup on n'attend
pas des grandes envolées lyriques on
attend plus ces histoires de guerre ça
ne fonctionne pas le président allemand
d'ailleurs l'a dit c'est pas une guerre
c'est une crise sanitaire qui testent
notre humanité
aujourd'hui on voit que les déclarations
du gouvernement et du medef ne vont pas
dans le sens de l'humanité mais plutôt
dans une grande régression où on va
demander aux français de travailler
davantage pour sauver l'économie
économique on va mettre à genoux parce
qu'on n'a pas les moyens de déconfit
n'est aujourd'hui donc on attend
simplement des chiffres on attend des
faits concrets des dates on a on ne veut
pas de discours churchillien de choses
comme ça ça ne sert à rien les français
ne veulent pas de la communication
politique
ils attendent simplement de l'action on
a vu le le chef d'état se rendre sur le
terrain on l'a vu notamment aller à
marseille sur la question de
de la chloroquine est ce que le chef de
l'état emmanuel macron est suffisamment
présents selon vous depuis le début de
cette pandémie
il est extrêmement présente mais dans un
cadre très strict qui est celui de sa
communication personnelle et pas
tellement finalement de gérer tout ce
qui va se passer parce qu'on voit que
quand il va à marseille il va voir un
peu en touriste didier raoult qui lui
montre comment ça fonctionne mais
pendant des mois on a l'impression que
la communication n'était pas installé
donc il y va parce qu'il se rend compte
que les français bien attendre une
réponse par rapport à cette fameuse que
robin par rapport à ces annonces de ce
professeur qui est mondialement reconnue
donc il n'est pas parce qu'il se dit si
j'y vais pas je vais passer pour quelqu
un docteur ou alors est donc on est
toujours dans une stratégie de
communication personnels les sorties à
pantin il va avoir des soignants qu'est
ce qu'il leur dit qu'est ce qui vous
manque à peu près tout ils n'apportent
pas de masque il n'apporte pas de
solution mais derrière il se fait
prendre en photo avec des gens qui au
balcon l'applaudissent ils utilisent ils
détournent la communication également ce
qu'il se passe au kremlin bicêtre le
matin le jeudi où il allait voir
professeurs ou l'après midi les
soignants s'applaudissent et lui utilise
des images sur le compte de l'elysée
pour faire croire que les soignants
l'applaudissent et lui c'est assez
catastrophique
c'est ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure c'est à dire qu'on a
l'impression que chaque prise de parole
chaque déplacement est dans le cadre
d'une communication personnelle et
politique qui n'a rien à voir avec la
gestion de cette crise preuve en est
l'association de la presse
présidentielle s'est plaint du fait que
les journalistes étaient très mal
traités mis à part des déplacements
présidentiels empêchés de faire leur
travail
on est dans une finale ment un exercice
de propagande bien plus qu'un exercice
de gestion de crise alors en amont pour
conclure le temps du déconfinement n'est
pas pour tout de suite on l'entend mais
quel scénario pourrait être envisagée
par le gouvernement français selon vous
alors moi j'ai pas les fuites du jdd je
peux pas vous dire ce qui est ce qui est
choisi leur côté j'attends de voir parce
que souvent on entend tout et son
contraire attendons de voir ce qu
annonce emmanuel macron demain mais
clairement les annonces du medef de
travailler plus et c
il ya une inquiétude réelle maintenant
sur une crise économique majeure
au delà de la récession une banqueroute
finalement du pays il va falloir trouver
une solution pour que les entreprises
reprennent dans le respect de la santé
des travailleurs à la fois la protection
avec les masques mais aussi
certainement pas des cadences infernales
comme ce qu'on est en train de proposer
au ministère du travail au medef
merci beaucoup alexis poulain d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes journaliste et cofondateur du
site
le monde moderne